dea
今から日本語のレッスンを行います
はいもしもしこんにちはアウト今日は船で鹿児島から奄美大島に行くものなんですが
台風がちょっと心配であっはい船に関してですが結構になりましたが結構
で
ですねそうですっ結構です結構ですね結構です結構多いですね結構ですいい怒った
アーサー安吾賞ウイルのパティいきます今日は家で古いシャンパンを開けようと思っ
てるんだ
のミニコーナーいく
う今日は家で古いシャンパンを開けようと思ってるんだ
飲んで来ない
ブーブーけどなんか凄くブスだって聞いた
あぁそうそうさあウードゥーうーん
ブーバだパイシュー病院へ引っ張っカー狂くださいはいわかりました
多いとイクターあっ
彼女くださいはーいー
[音楽]
どう切りましょうかねぇ何かイメージがありますか
そうですねさっぱりした髪にしてくださいってことは
アポロみたいな感じの方がいいかなと思うんだけどどうかな
うんそれで以降のほうがいいかなと思うんだけどどうかな
するか
すいませんね突然皆さんを呼び出して実は大事な報告がありまして
あ久美子にプロポーズしたのかなはい組ことやとこんにゃくをしました
たこんにゃくじゃなくて血管を血管って言いません結果効果れ大丈夫
結構22
ありました
先日妻と一緒に海に行ってきた
先日家内と一緒に海に行ってきた先日女房と一緒に海に行ってきた
先日奥さんと一緒に海に行ってきた
新しい水着カチッ
鈴木寛なんて言ってくれるかな
先日ワイフと一緒に海に行ってきたうん
ni